le talent c'est dire comment je vais
arriver quelque chose de nouveau comment
je vais étonner les gens moi je
t'appelle nouveau félix le nouveau
vigneault j'étais moi puis là quand il
ya des téléréalités y cherche le nouveau
daniel boucher ou la nouvelle isabelle
boulay et s'ils sortent du moule 90
centraux du monde sait ça c'est une
mauvaise façon et tout est en train de
naître niveler par le bas et que tu va
regarder ce qui se fait à new york où
numéro est pré 2 les français la semaine
d'après fond ce qui a nui au lieu
d'essayer de d'inventer le trouvons vous
étiez en californie oui pourquoi ceux du
front oui vous allez trouver là beaucoup
d'inspiration
oui moi je sortais des catacombes qui
étaient les boîtes à chansons hélas
quand j'allais voir les groupes comme
photo getty hoffman ou les birds ou
janis qui s'appelait big brother and
company je me disais mais c'est pas du
monde qui s'appelle un groupe pas ce qui
se déguisent
ils vont les gants blancs aux habits
jaunes ils sont un groupe parce qu'ils
se mettent le jean qui travaillent en
rompuy se mettre ensemble dans une cave
pour trouver des nouvelles choses et ces
deux là que je quand je suis revenu de
californie j'ai écouté le on va pas
facile et les romains se passe à un gros
puis tout le monde je croyais à la
collaboration des talents et la
collaboration des talents ben c'est ce
qui fait qu'on fait une émission parce
que si lui est pas là tout passe dans ce
lot cause et c'est vrai pour tous les
grands faits les les grands tableaux les
grandes chansons